翻訳: Yuko Shirakawa
校正: Riaki Poništ
私は いじめ問題を扱う弁護士です
これまでたくさんの学校で
いじめに関する授業をし
たくさんの先生方から
相談を受けてきました
実は 私は法学部出身の
弁護士ではありません
教育学部出身です
教員免許も持っています
ですから教育問題に
とても関心があり
ご縁があっていじめに
関わるようになりました
ではそもそも なぜ私が弁護士を
目指したのか というところなんですけど
あえて一言で言うならば
それはテレビドラマの影響です
昔 天海祐希さんが弁護士役を
演じるドラマがありました
その弁護士が
とても格好良く 輝いて見えて
私もあんなふうになりたい
と憧れた訳です
ドラマの中での天海さんは
いつも正しい とても正しい事を言います
ですから私も彼女のように
真っすぐと正しい事が言える弁護士になりたい
と思っていましたし
今でもそう思っています
しかしながら
私が扱ういじめ問題では
正しい事を言っても
相手の心に届かない事があります
今日はその一部を少しだけ
ご紹介したいと思います
弁護士になって
いじめ問題に取り組み始めた頃
私はいじめの「語られ方」に
ある特徴がある事に気づきました
それは とてもドラマティックに
とてもセンセーショナルに
感情的に語られるという事です
テレビなどを通して
大人が子供に語るのは
「こんな酷いいじめがあったよ」
「こんな悲しい結果
酷い結果が生じたよ」と言うのです
そして最後に
「大事な命が失われるから
いじめは絶対やってはいけない」
と言うのです
これは私にとってあまりに
当たり前の事であったため
気づいた という事自体に
自分でも少し驚きました
そして これに気づいた事で
自分がなかなか難しい道を
進んでいく事になるという事に
最初は全然気づいていませんでした
冒頭でも申し上げた通り
私は教育学部出身の弁護士なので
せっかくいじめに関わるのであれば
中高生向けに いじめに関する
授業を作ろうと思いました
そして いじめに対する
考え方を養えるように
１つの事例に対して みんなで
議論できるような授業を作りました
事例の内容はこんな感じです
ある子が 同じグループの
別の子からDVDを借ります
しかし その子は
そのDVDをなかなか返さないうえに
やっと返したかと思ったら
それに傷をつけて返してしまいます
それがきっかけで その子はグループの
みんなから仲間外れにされてしまう
そして学校に来たくなくなってしまう
というものです
みなさんはこれを聞いて
最初にまず何を思いましたか
幾つかの学校でやってみて
私は少しだけ驚きました
思っていたよりも
「こんなものはいじめじゃない」
という意見がずっと多かったからです
「悪い事をした人は
仲間外れにされて当然だ」
「クラス全員から無視された訳でもない」
「一部の生徒たちからハブられたぐらいで
いじめというのはおかしい」
どの意見も とても強いものでした
また 私の事例は テレビで—
NHKのテレビですとか ラジオですとか
そういったものでも紹介されているため
大人からも沢山のご意見を頂きました
やはり「いじめではない」
という意見はそれなりにあって
「自分はもっと酷い
いじめを受けていた」
「こんなものまで いじめと言ったら
子供が弱くなる」
「何でもかんでも いじめと言ったら
コミュニケーションできなくなる」
などという意見もありました
つまり この程度のものであれば
良くある事 些細な事
いじめと言うには
大袈裟すぎる という訳です
なぜ 大袈裟だと思うのでしょうか
それはおそらく「いじめ」と言ったら
テレビで見るような酷いもの
命に関わりそうなもの
あるいは 何の落ち度もない
可哀想な被害者を
イメージするからだと思います
私たちは口々に「いじめをやめよう」
「 やめよう」と言っていますが
そこで 「やめよう」とされているいじめは
もしかするとテレビで
見るような酷いものや
被害者側に何の落ち度もないものだけ
かも知れないという事です
分かりやすさのために
絵を用意しました
縦軸が行為の程度
これは主に集団が行う行為です
横軸が相手の苦痛の程度です
いじめは集団心理もあって
どんどんエスカレート
していくのが特徴です
他方で 相手の苦痛の程度も
それに伴ってどんどん増していきます
そして その苦痛に
どれくらい耐えられるか というのは
個人差があるうえに
外からは分かりません
いつ限界がきてしまうか
分からない訳です
ですから エスカレートした
酷いものだけを「いじめ」として
それを「やめよう」「 やめよう」
と言っていても
本当のいじめ対策にはなりません
むしろ 手遅れになってしまう
場合の方が多い訳です
しかしながら 私たちがイメージする
「いじめ」というのは
主にこの部分
限界直前のこの部分です
ですから「大事な命が失われるから
いじめはやめよう」という
語られ方になるのです
では 残りのこの部分は
何なんでしょう
ここはやめなくていいんでしょうか
もしやめた方がいいのであれば
それはなぜなんでしょう
私はこの部分にこそ
いじめ問題の本質を考える
ヒントがあると思っています
ですから 先ほどのような
事例を使って
生徒さんたちと一緒に
この問題を考えている訳です
ちなみに法律は 相手の苦痛が
スタートする この部分から
全体を「いじめ」と考えています
いじめを小さいうちに発見して
重大化を防止するためです
ですから私が先ほど取り上げた
事例のようなものも「いじめ」
法律上の「いじめ」という事になります
さて こういったものまでも
「いじめ」という事になると
生徒さん達の次に困惑するのが
現場の先生方です
先生方からすれば
いじめる方も いじめられる方も
大事な生徒です
可愛い生徒たちに
いじめっ子や いじめられっ子の
レッテルを張りたくありません
ですから被害者や加害者といった
力関係のようなものが生じてしまう
「いじめ」ではなく
「トラブル」としてこの問題に
対応したいと考えるようです
私はこれまで沢山の生徒さんたちと
関わってきましたし
先生方とも一緒に
お仕事をしてきました
ですから この気持ちは
とても良く分かります
しかしながら 私は
この解決方法には反対です
なぜならば こういう事が
起きるからです
私は この問題に初めて直面したのは
授業後のアンケートでした
そこには こう書いてありました
「担任の先生が この事例は
いじめる方も いじめられる方も
どちらも悪いと言っていました
私もそう思います
私は人から借りたものを
大切にしようと思います」
この一見 どこも問題の
なさそうな この感想
これがいわゆる
「いじめられる方も悪い」という理屈です
これは とても危険な対応です
なぜならば いじめをエスカレートさせる
可能性があるからです
集団を 一定程度 正当化してしまう
そういった側面があります
ですから これは
とても危険な対応です
当然ですが 相手に落ち度が
あるからといって
いじめていい事にはなりません
いじめというのは「手段の選択」です
何か 腹が立ったり 苛立ったり
そうした時に それを解決する手段は
たくさんあります
相手と話し合ったり
少し時間を置いたり
仲裁してくれる誰かを
連れてきたり
そうした全ての手段を放棄して
敢えて相手に苦痛を与える
という手段を
「選択」している訳です
「その手段は間違っているんだよ」
「やっちゃいけないんだよ」
「ダメなんだよ」という事を
大人は子供にきちんと
教えてあげる必要があると思います
そこを曖昧にしてはいけないのです
では なぜダメなのか
なぜやってはいけないのか
それは人の尊厳を
傷つけるからです
尊厳というのはその人が
周りの人とか家族とか
そうした人達から
愛されてきたり
あるいは自分自身が迷ったり
苦しんだりしながらも
一つ一つ積み上げてきた
その人がその人であるための
核のようなものです
いじめはそれを否定し
傷つけ 壊します
だから やってはいけないのです
確かに仲間外れや無視
からかいなどは
外から見れば大した事ではない
些細な事 良くある事
なのかもしれません
しかしながら私たち大人は
知っています
それが自分に向けられた時に
いかに深く傷つくか
どれほど 自分が自分である事の
自信を失うか
そして その失った自信が
容易には回復しない
という事も知っています
また逆に相手の尊厳を傷つける事が
いかに重大で
どれほど のちに後悔するか
という事も知っているはずです
大人が子供にいじめを語る時
自分の被害経験を語る人はいても
加害経験を語る人は
ほとんどいません
理屈の上では 被害者の数よりも
加害者の数の方が多いはず
であるにもかかわらずです
それだけ のちに後悔し
そっと心の内にしまっている大人が
多いという事です
ですから私たち大人は
子供たちに対し
人の尊厳が傷つけられるから
いじめはやってはいけない
それは相手の命が失われるとか
失われないとか
そういう事は関係ない
という事を
正面から論じる必要が
あると思います
そこに向き合う必要が
それは 私がこれまで
歩んできたように
とても難しい事なのかもしれません
たくさんの大人たちや子供たちから
「でも」とか「だって」とか
「そんなの綺麗ごとだ」とか
「それは偽善者だ」とか
そういった事を
言われるかもしれません
また あるいは被害者に対し
「そんな風だから
仲間外れにされてしまうんだよ」
「それも社会勉強のうちだよ」
などと思ってしまい
自分自身が試される事も
あるかもしれません
それでも私たち大人たちが
試行錯誤を繰り返しながら
この問題に向き合い続けていく事が
大切なのではないかと思うのです
それが 一人一人が
自分らしく生きられる社会
個人が尊重される社会に
繋がっていくのではないかと思うのです
借り物に傷をつけるような
失敗をしたかもしれない
一人だけチームの輪を
乱したかもしれない
空気が読めないかもしれない
誰かを傷つけて
しまったかもしれない
一人だけ みんなと
違うかもしれない
そうしたきっかけで
仲間外れや無視
からかいをされて
苦しんでる人たちがいます
もしかしたら自分が
悪いのかもしれないと
じっと耐えてる人たちがいます
私はそうした人たちに
「それはいじめなんだよ」
「いけない事なんだよ」
「声をあげていいんだよ」
「辛いと言っていいんだよ」
と言ってあげられる—
大人でありたいと思っています
そのために これからも この問題と
向き合っていきたいと思っています
これが私がたくさんの
人たちに助けられながら
一つ一つ積み上げてきた—
私が私である為の核です
ご清聴ありがとうございました
（拍手）